pleased to say the General Secretary of
the TUC Paul Novak joins us now Paul
good morning to you thanks for being
with us this morning now you've talked
about a fair deal for workers the nurses
are asking for five percent above RPI
inflation is that a fair deal
considering the pay restraints that the
government must have in place well
listen we've got 133 000 vacancies in
our NHS at the moment we've got a
staffing crisis and I don't think
another real terms pay cut for nurses
but not just nurses for paramedics for
physiotherapists for anybody working on
our NHS is going to help solve that
staff Staffing crisis so I think what's
important now Kamal is that we've got
ministers who are empowered to talk
about pay with unions and to listen to
their own Workforce so yesterday I wrote
to the Prime Minister and asked him to
urgently meet with me and other union
leaders but crucially he's got allow his
ministers to get around a table with our
unions and reach a fair settlement on
pay what their Fair settlement is going
to look like I can't say and I can't
negotiate live on your program this
morning but we really do need to have
those negotiations you suggest that you
want it to be above inflation and
inflation's running at what 10.7 right
now yeah but as I say it's not my job to
negotiate the pay of our nurses or
paramedics or anybody else what I'm
saying is those workers very clearly and
I was on those picket lines with the
paramedics just before Christmas each
and every one of those workers told me
they can't afford another year of a real
terms pay cut the reality is their
mortgages are going up their food bills
are going up their rental mortgages are
going up the only thing that isn't going
up is their their wages and I think the
government has to take some
responsibility here now step up to the
plate facilitate those talks let's get a
fair pay settlement for our NHS workers
but indeed public sector workers right
across the piece and you've asked for a
meeting with the Prime Minister you've
sent the letter what today when you're
expecting a response and what do you
think he will say to you well I would
hope you recognize the urgency of a
meeting and just to say I mean during
the pandemic the TC work very closely
with Rishi sunak and developing the
fairlow scheme alongside the CBI it
seems that the Prime Minister has
forgotten some of those basic lessons
from the pandemic that actually we come
up with better solution when we work
together and you know the NHS Staffing
crisis isn't going to solve itself
neither is the Staffing crisis in other
parts of our Public Services one is six
new teachers leaves the profession
within a year of qualifying there is
something wrong with our public services
and that's what happens when you have a
decade of underfunding under Staffing
and real terms pay cut to a public
sector workers I mean you say he's
forgotten some of the principles what do
you think he's forgotten I think he's
forgotten the value of sitting down and
reaching an agreement and and taking
ideas from people outside his own
cabinets and frankly you know I think
it'd be really good for issue soon act
to talk to our unions but also to talk
to some of those Frontline paramedics
those physiotherapists the teachers in
the classrooms civil servants people who
for the last decade have been placed
under real pressures on workload who
feel at breaking points let the Prime
Minister talk to those workers and
understand their concerns and their
issues I think that's what any decent
employer would do and it's someone
responsible for the employment of
millions of public sector workers that's
exactly what the Prime Minister should
do as well and of course the government
will say that there are pay offers on
the table for nurses there are pay
offers on the table for some of the
other people who are out on strike so
this is not a case of them not listening
this is a case of of unions trying to
demand even more that's unaffordable at
this point it's not a case of unions
demand and the unaffordable politics is
all about choices and the government has
got some big Clear Choices in front of
us in front of it it could for example
decide to tax more heavily the excess
profits of the oil and gas companies it
could decide to tax wealth in the same
way taxes incomes but the reality is
each and every single one of our public
sector workers at the moment faces a
real terms pay cut and that comes on the
back of a decade of pay cuts the average
nurse four thousand pound a year worse
off than if their pay would have risen
by the rate of inflation since 2008
something has got to give and I think
the Prime Minister needs to listen to
his own Workforce let's talk a little
bit more about nursing things you've
brought them up again you say
something's got to give now as I said
they're asking for five percent above
RPI now when they asked for that back
back in the summer I think it was going
to run about 14 would be the payoff for
now as we know it's around about 19 do
you think that this might be a misstep
in their strategy and would you like to
see them come back
with a different demand listen the
Dynamics always change in a pay
negotiation once you're sat around a
table but what we've got at the city at
moments is for example Steve Barkley
just before Christmas our health
secretary in the midst of a dispute
around pay as said he'll talk to our
unions about anything other than pay I
just don't think that's tenable and the
only way you're going to pay review
boards you deal with that uh listen the
government has been using the
independent review buddies as a human
shield and I think is in real danger of
discrediting those bodies when those
bodies met and made their
recommendations we didn't have inflation
running at 10 11 the government in its
evidence those pay review bodies set the
very clear Financial parameters that the
bodies could work within so listen let's
not hide behind the pay review bodies
what we need is the government to sit
around the table with our unions and
reach an agreement I mean there are
serious calls that important some
accusations as well that perhaps the
government is not being entirely fair in
this negotiations now you want to have a
meeting with the Prime Minister about
this are you going to tell him that you
think he's sabotaging the negotiations
they're not being fair well absolutely I
mean I I'll say to the Prime Minister
directly what I'd say uh to you uh this
morning and you know the key thing for
me I'm not interested in political Point
scoring I'm not interested in meeting
the the Prime Minister just for you know
uh Tea and Sympathy or indeed beer and
sandwiches I'm interested in meeting the
Prime Minister our unions are interested
in meeting the prime minister so we can
resolve these disputes and put pay in
the pockets of hard work and public
service workers and deliver the public
services that the people of this country
deserve and the Public's verdict is
pretty clear two-thirds of the public
blame the government for mishandling
these strikes it's time for the
government to listen to the public
listen to its own Workforce get round
the table with unions and while many of
course will accept those uh calls by the
public sector workers
um there is a real hit to the economy by
some of these strikes not of course not
with nurses rights but with the train
driver strikes and the train worker
strikes some 2.5 billion pounds lost to
the economy I mean as the country's
saying that it can't afford to raise
wages it can't afford to deal with the
the loss to income that is getting from
the strike action well there's a real
hypocrisy here because every single day
of strike action while rail workers are
losing pay the government is effectively
underwriting the losses of the
privatized trained companies that makes
no Financial sense whatsoever and the
other thing that really sucks demand out
of local economies is when rail workers
or indeed nurses teachers Supermarket
workers don't have money in their
pockets to spend in local shops and
restaurants now are our rail unions are
very clear they want those disputes
resolved they want their members back to
work they regret any impact on the
economy but the responsibility for these
strikes the responsibility for the
strikes in the public sector lies very
clearly with the governments I mean that
regret is of course truly felt but these
strikes are going on I spoke to Michael
and Chester they said they could run on
for months to come he's got a mandate up
until May you'll know that many mandates
run until it well into the new year how
do you expect these strikes to continue
because the strike action so far has not
had anything like the effect you'd like
it to have on the government making
those decisions well I think it's had a
very clear impact on on public opinion
and I know I know talking to people who
walk past that picket line uh in
Waterloo a couple of weeks ago the
public are very clear when it comes to a
straight fight between Rishi sunak
Jeremy Hunt and Steve Barkley and our
nurses and paramedics I know where
public sympathy lies I would like the
government to listen to the concerns of
their own workforces forget me forget
union leaders think about the millions
of people day in Day Out Who deliver our
Public Services the least the government
could do is show them the respect of
listening to them talking to them and
reach an agreement if they don't you're
not in a general strike yet but there
are consecutive days of action it feels
like almost like a general strike is
that where you go to next how does this
how do you increase the pressure well
well you know it's a really difficult
decision for any worker who takes strike
action they do lose pay they don't get
to deliver the services that they're
proud to deliver so my responsibility
the responsibility of our unions is when
members take that difficult decision we
have to make sure that that is as
impactful as possible and as effective
as possible so we're always talking to
our unions about how we make sure we
maximize the impact of industrial action
how we maximize the call on the
government I you know I don't want to be
in a position least of all our public
sector workers don't want to be in a
position where people are taking strike
action but really the ball is in the
government's Court they need to talk to
their own Workforce we've seen employers
right across the private sector where
workers have taken industrial action
listen to their own workforces and reach
agreements and I dare to the government
to do the same so there can be more
coordination you want to see more
pressure being put forward well I think
it absolutely makes sense for example in
education and in health where you've got
a number of different unions for unions
to talk to each other about how we
support each other coordinate our action
that makes absolute sense it's clear on
what you're saying here so support your
other coordinary action that means going
out on the same day all out on strike no
it doesn't necessarily mean that at all
uh Kamali I mean it may actually be
better to to have a focus for
particularly groups of workers on
particular days and you know what what
what I'm really interested in is not
posturing or grand strategizing what I'm
really interested in is getting a
resolution for public sector workers and
you know I as I say I would urge the
prime minister to talk to our units and
talk to those Frontline workers because
I think they deserve the respect of
being listened to and their concerns
taken on board is there is there a
concern is there a danger in this action
and if it does increase in ways that
you're describing the the government try
and push through some more of those
anti-strike laws and I know that I'm
sure that will be something you
discussed with the Prime Minister as
well if you get that meeting I mean that
that is a real
um uh danger I think it would be a real
mistake from the government because what
that would be doing is treating the
symptoms of the strikes rather than the
underlying causes which is those real
terms uh pay cuts but let me be
absolutely clear if the Prime Minister
brings forward more legislation to make
it even more difficult for workers to
take strike action the TUC will fight
that will fight that politically we'll
fight it
um legally as well we already have a
legal challenge in with the government
11 TUC unions challenging the
government's decision to allow employers
to use agency workers to break strikes
we think the governments will be very
close to a breach in fundamental
International labor law and we'd ask
them to to step back from that Brink and
rather than messing around with the
right to strike what they should be
doing is negotiating settlement to these
disputes and delivering a fair pay rise
for public sector workers okay pull no
back from CCO do you appreciate your
time this morning thank you very much
for coming